et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Aurélien pratique bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous député du Lot
vice-président executif des républicains
en étant ensemble pendant 20 minutes
pour une interview en partenariat avec
la presse régionale représentée par
Stéphane Vernet de Ouest-France bonjour
Stéphane bonjour on va évidemment parler
de la réforme des retraites sans grande
surprise Aurélien Pradier les débats se
sont donc ouvert hier dans une ambiance
électrique on va y revenir mais ils se
sont ouverts en l'absence d'Elizabeth
borne qui a laissé Olivier du soft et
Gabriel Attal sur le banc des ministres
vous le comprenez
j'ai pas de commentaire à faire sur sur
sa position ce qui est certain c'est que
il faut que la première ministre se dise
bien que rien ne sera possible sans le
soutien des parlementaires nous sommes
dans une démocratie parlementaire et il
faudrait pas progressivement s'habituer
à ce qu'on puisse mépriser le Parlement
l'agiter comme la nupes le fait
aujourd'hui le Parlement c'est un lieu
qui se respecte et je pense que j'aurais
été à sa place mais je ne le suis pas
vous l'avez observé je pense que c'était
un signe de respect à l'égard des
parlementaires même si dans l'hémicycle
les agitations étaient assez
insupportables d'être là pour dire que
le gouvernement était largement
représenté par la première ministre je
pense d'ailleurs que c'est globalement
ce qui s'est toujours fait au monde du
démarrage d'une grande réforme comme
celle-ci c'est un geste qui à mon avis
n'aurait sûrement pas apaisé les agités
de la nupes aussi pour vous savez c'est
une série de détails je sais que ça peut
paraître anodin mais moi j'observe
depuis maintenant quelques années ça
fait 6 ans que je suis député que petit
à petit on oublie des gestes qui étaient
aussi des gestes de respect du Parlement
il s'agit pas de respecter les députés
il s'agit de respecter les Français que
nous représentons justement vous parlez
de l'ambiance électrique le débit de
discussion était très agité hier dans
l'hémicycle la nuque demandait que sa
notion référendaire soit examinée ça
doit donner lieu à plusieurs appels au
règlement à des suspensions de séance à
interrompu le discours de l'évier du
soft à peine commencé vous comprenez
leur position et leur attitude non je
n'ai pas la comprendre mais tout ça rend
service au gouvernement peut-être même
que le gouvernement c'est en délecte un
peu tu sais moi je suis stupéfait de
voir depuis quelques jours que désormais
tout le banc et l'arrière banc du
gouvernement font de la nupesse leur
adversaire princip tout ça pour les
faire monter tout ça pour les faire
exister et je vois bien qu'il y ait un
espèce de match stérile qui s'installe
entre le camp des uns et le camp des
autres alors que cette réforme là elle
mérite un débat d'une toute autre tenue
et je pense qu'au fond la nups sont en
train de devenir les idiots utiles du
gouvernement tout comme le gouvernement
se satisfait avec un cynisme qui moi me
déconcerte depuis déjà plusieurs mois
que les plus énervés de cette hémicycle
soient ceux qui se fassent le plus
entendre tout ça va se calmer il y a 15
jours de débats ce qui hurle au début
cette discussion il y aura 15 jours de
débat moi j'ai bien l'intention de
participer à ces 15 jours de débat et
nous serons là pour rappeler y compris à
nos collègues de la nupesse que il ne
rende service à personne certainement
pas aux idées qu'il défendent les seuls
auxquels les rendre service et le
gouvernement c'est peut-être un peu
technique mais il faudrait quand même
expliquer cette histoire d'émotion
référendaire il y a le brun Pivet a eu
raison d'écarter cette la motion
référendaire présentée par l'alliotte
est-ce qu'il pouvait le faire
c'est l'autorité de la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale flou dans le
règlement en fait
il y a un fou qui a été exploité je suis
pas sûr que la majorité soit extrêmement
claire surtout cela et vous savez
l'enseignement que je tire de manière
plus générale c'est la façon dont nous
avons de nous habituer à un mode dégradé
de notre démocratie est-ce qu'on va
désormais
qu'il y en aura d'autres ce qui en est
le moins possible mais je souhaite que
nous débattuons sur le fond c'est pas
une promenade de santé la réforme des
retraites et évidemment qu'il ne s'agit
pas que y compris à l'Assemblée
nationale nous ne débattuons pas nous ne
feraillons pas on est là aussi pour
faire en sorte que la colère des
Français soit entendue mais là on voit
la colère mais est-ce que c'est possible
de débattre avec plus de 20 000
abattements déposés hier soir il y a eu
30 amendements identiques qui ont été
examinés à la dans la dans la foulée le
début d'examen du d'article 1 du texte
n'a même pas commencé est-ce qu'il est
peu de matériellement possible d'aller
au bout de ce texte compte tenu des
conditions ne me demandez pas défendre
les collègues de la nupesse je ne les ai
jamais défendus moi je n'ai pas fait
d'obstruction mes collègues n'a n'ont
pas fait non plus après on a un petit
sujet dès le départ qui est
l'utilisation de nartifice d'un outil
constitutionnel qui est celui du 47,1
qui permet dans un temps limité
d'examiner un texte dans le cadre d'un
projet de loi de finance rectificatif ce
qui n'a jamais été le cas pour un projet
de réforme des retraites enfin tous les
ingrédients je les fais parce que je
veux des explications et des garanties
sur la constitutionnalité de la
procédure non pas encore mais j'ai un
sérieux doute à la fois sur la
constitutionnalité globale de la
procédure mais aussi sur le danger qu'il
y ait à ce que plusieurs des grandes
mesures que nous voulons faire adopter
je pense notamment à l'annulation de la
ponction sur l'agir que Arrco à la
réforme des régimes spéciaux à la
question de l'index des seniors n'est
pas d'impact sur le projet de loi de
finance de la sécurité sociale de cette
année et donc puisse être censuré à
posteriori par le Conseil
constitutionnel ce qui viderait
d'éléments essentiels la loi que nous
allons débattre en réalité depuis
l'origine chacun joue sur une corde
raide et je pense qu'il y a un problème
originel qui est la volonté de passage
en force du gouvernement vous êtes en
train de nous dire que à la fin des fins
de toute façon la loi pourrait être
toquée par le Conseil constitution je ne
suis pas membre du Conseil
constitutionnel mais mon travail est de
prendre des précautions je dis au
gouvernement ne nous faites pas danser
pendant 15 jours ne nous faites pas
adopter des mesures dont vous seriez
conscient par avance quelles vont être
sanctionnées par le Conseil
constitutionnel vous pensez que le
gouvernement
l'article 47 1 et 47 il est très clair
il dit que toutes les mesures concernées
doivent être en lien avoir un impact
avec le budget du projet de loi de
finance de la sécurité sociale sur
l'année en cours est-ce que le
l'annulation de la ponction agir que
Arrco à un impact sur cet exercice
budgétaire est-ce que l'index senior a
un impact la réponse est non est-ce que
les régimes spéciaux dans le
gouvernement nous dit qu'il va les
reporter au calendr grec avec la clause
du grand-père est-ce que cela a un
impact sur un exercice budgétaire du
PLFSS la réponse est non et c'est donc
nécessaire légitimement qu'un député se
pose des questions ne serait-ce pour que
en on ne fasse pas je le redis danser
inutilement pendant 15 jours en n'ayant
parfaitement conscience que des éléments
essentiels de nos débats risquent d'être
sanctionné par le Conseil
constitutionnel sur la question du
travail c'est une bonne solution pour
vous mais il va falloir le dire
aujourd'hui enfin qu'est ce que c'est
que ce mode de fonctionnement
parlementaire rendez compte en début de
l'examen d'un texte tous les
négociations se font en dehors du
Parlement c'est-à-dire en dehors de la
représentation nationale on dit que
peut-être en effet il y a des éléments
absolument essentiels des dispositifs et
de nos discussions avec le gouvernement
qui seront sanctionnés après et que
peut-être il y aura un nouveau projet de
loi enfin que la règle du jeu soit fixée
dès le début y compris pour que nous
puissions la respecter
sur le fond de ce texte est-ce qu'après
le début de la discussion le groupe LR a
acté sa position il y avait une réunion
hier soir des républicains commencent à
s'est passé qu'elle va être votre
position ça c'est bien passé hier on se
parle et encore des divergences est-ce
qu'elles sont un sourire c'est pas
certain oui entre nous moi j'ai une
position qui n'a pas varié alors je sais
je vais essuyer pendant quelques
semaines le mépris la condescendance de
tous ceux qui font mettre pression pour
que nous sédions au gouvernement que
nous acceptons que ça suffit on a assez
défendu assez obtenu de choses bien moi
je ne le crois pas c'est chez vous qui a
dépression
tout le monde il va de sa petite
complainte et c'est plutôt légitime ce
qui est certain non pas des riches tout
le monde considère que désormais tous
les cas certains il est temps de dire au
gouvernement que que c'est parfait que
tout va bien c'est pas ce que je crois
d'ailleurs je ne pense pas que l'iris ni
mes amis ne le croient totalement je
veux revenir au début de l'histoire il y
a quelques semaines vous m'avez entendu
poser une ligne rouge cette ligne rouge
n'a cette ligne rouge a consiste à dire
tous ceux qui ont commencé avant 21 ans
ne peuvent pas être pénalisés parce que
lorsque vous commencez tôt vous avez un
salaire qui est souvent plus bas que les
autres vous avez des conditions de
travail plus difficiles
Elisabeth borne a annoncé une
disposition qui fait que les carrières
longues dispositif très spécifique
pardon vont être élargis au moins de 21
ans est-ce que ça suffit la réponse est
non pourquoi parce que vous demandiez
c'est votre livre rouge ce n'est pas ce
que je demandais ce que je demandais
c'est que dès lors que vous aviez
commencé avant 21 ans avec vos 43
annuités de cotisation ou plus vous
étiez en mesure de partir à la retraite
et les abeilles borne propose qu'on est
temps d'un dispositif très spécifique
issu des carrières longues au moins de
21 ans or pour être éligible aux
carrières longues il vous faut avoir
cotisé 5 trimestres avant vos 21 ans
figurez-vous que aujourd'hui la moitié
des Français qui ont commencé à
travailler avant 21 ans ne sont pas
éligibles au dispositif de carrière
longue ajoutons que pour être éligible
au dispositif de carrière longue il ne
vous faut jusqu'à la fin de votre
carrière n'avoir jamais plus connu par
exemple plus de 4 trimestres
d'invalidité ou d'inactivité ce qui veut
dire que c'est très sélectif nous avions
proposé autre chose Isabelle propose
cela quelle est la conséquence de sa
proposition est-ce que par exemple ceux
qui ont commencé à travailler à 17 ans
vont être sauvés par la proposition de
Elizabeth borne la réponse est non
figurez-vous que après les annonces
Elizabeth borne ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler à 17 ans ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler à 16 ans ceux qui
ont commencé à travailler à 18 ans vont
cotiser 44 annuités vous savez combien
de temps celui qui a commencé à
travailler à 30 ans va cotiser 43
annuités quelle est une réforme juste
dans laquelle subsiste encore ce point
là qui fait que celui qui a commencé à
travailler à 17 ans va devoir travailler
une année de plus que celui qui a
commencé à 30 ans et c'est un point qui
n'est pas réglé par les annonces
Elizabeth borne voilà pourquoi je
résiste encore et je ne le fais pas pour
le plaisir de faire le malin récupéré
que veut récupérer le gouvernement avec
cette réforme vient de là comment vous
équilibrez du coup vous supprimez ces
dispositions qui peut aujourd'hui
droit dans les yeux dire aux Français
nous allons chercher de l'argent pour
financer le système de retraite en
tapant sur ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler à 16 ans 17 ans et 18 ans qui
peut assumer ça est-ce que ça a du sens
politiquement ça n'a aucun sens
politiquement est-ce que ça a du sens
budgétairement rappelons-nous que nous
consacrons 8 milliards d'euros chaque
année aux pensions d'invalidité les
pensions d'invalidité elle concerne
principalement ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler tôt si vous tapez fortement
sur ceux qui ont commencé à travailler
tôt d'abord vous êtes injustes et pour
moi qui fait de la politique avec des
valeurs c'est insupportable et ensuite
vous êtes financièrement
inefficace ce que vous entendez le
message du gouvernement idiot on est
ouvert aux améliorations à condition que
l'équilibre de du système ne soit pas
menacé si on enlève de l'argent quelque
part il faut le trouver ailleurs vous le
trouver le report à 64 ans permet de
gagner de l'argent disons-le clairement
il le permet notamment parce que
beaucoup de Français vont devoir aller
travailler plus longtemps notamment pour
bénéficier de la surcote et c'est pas un
détail
quelque chose de très significatif y
compris pour les ressources de l'État
mais je le redis allez taper sur celles
et ceux qui ont commencé à travailler
tôt cette politiquement injustable c'est
socialement injuste et ses
financièrement
inefficaces mais je le redis sur le fait
qu'il faut avoir fait un trimestre avant
21 ans pour pouvoir bénéficier du
dispositif parce que du coup ça concerne
beaucoup le monde par exemple pour les
étudiants qui ont fait des jobs d'été
ils ont un trimestre avant de l'avant
vers 21 ans ce que j'ai toujours défendu
c'est que la durée de cotisation devait
écraser las vegan il se trouve que ce
n'est pas l'option que le gouvernement a
choisi mais ce n'est peut-être pas mon
choix initial c'est une option que nous
avons débattue il faut pas toucher à
l'âge légal il faut se concentrer
uniquement sur la durée de cotisation on
reportage
de réforme des retraites auxquelles je
croyais c'était celui qui jouait sur la
durée de cotisation il se trouve que le
gouvernement a fait un autre choix
c'était pas ce que j'ai dit est-ce que
vous m'avez entendu une seule fois dire
que je refusais de reporter l'âge légal
non je ne l'ai jamais dit j'ai cherché
un aménagement avec mes collègues
députés
je n'ai pas changé d'avis sauf que il y
a un texte porté par le gouvernement qui
n'est pas le mien il nous a pas échappé
que je n'étais pas au gouvernement et
donc je cherche à l'améliorer le plus
fortement possible il y a encore un
point d'amélioration qui n'est pas
obtenu c'est que tous ceux qui sont
avant 21 ans je refuse catégoriquement
que ce soit les noms de la farce il me
semble tout de même que ce principe là
il n'est pas indéfendable et si vous
trouvez un seul responsable politique
pour aller voir nos concitoyens en leur
disant oui toi tu as commencé à
travailler à 17 ans ou à 18 ans tu es
celui de travail le plus durement c'est
toi qui va payer pour les autres
puisque vous avez une réunion est-ce que
c'est une position qui est partagée par
l'ensemble des député la républicains et
nous avons eu un débat nous l'aurons
encore en réunion de groupe tout à
l'heure je suis convaincu que nous
devons tenir bon sur cette disposition
là que l'on ne peut pas pénaliser ceux
qui ont commencé à travailler tôt après
moi je ne claque pas de porte seulement
j'ai des convictions j'essaie de les
défendre c'est mon amendement n'est pas
repris à la virgule près je dis que si
celles et ceux qui pour moi a été
rattrapé par l'amendement que nous
portions qui n'est pas mon amende
par tous les députés du groupe alors oui
je serai opposé à la réforme on a encore
15 jours de débats peut-être que la
gouvernement va bouger sur ce sujet je
n'en sais rien vous vous pourriez aussi
trouver un compromis entre votre
amendement et la position du
gouvernement mais je ne cesse de le
faire depuis des semaines vous l'avez
rappelé il y a quelques instants lors de
la campagne interne et je n'ai pas
changé d'avis j'étais opposé au seul
recul de l'âge légal je crois que c'est
la durée de cotisation qui est le plus
efficace j'ai bougé sur ce sujet y
compris pour que au sein de notre groupe
nous soyons plus fort mais moi vous
savez le seul pacte que j'ai c'est avec
les Français pas avec Elizabeth borne
Elizabeth borne c'est pas ma complice
c'est pas ma pote c'est pas avec elle
que j'ai à c'est pas elle que j'ai à
faire plaisir c'est pas Elizabeth band
que je veux soigner c'est pas les
aberbes que je veux entendre ce que je
veux c'est défendre les gouvernements
c'est défendre nos concitoyens pas le
gouvernement et sur ce point là je pense
que y compris mes amis politiques
peuvent comprendre que nous devions nous
devons consacrer plus d'énergie à
défendre les Français qu'à défendre le
gouvernement
d'hier vous y voyez plus au sein du
groupe LR sur qui est prêt à voter la
réforme avec les compromis fait par
Elisabeth borne et qui comme vous n'êtes
toujours pas prêt à la voter nous avons
au sein du groupe une divergence entre
ceux qui n'ont pas changé d'avis et ceux
qui ont dans l'équilibre j'en sais rien
vous êtes une centaine ça représente
combien de calcul mais à mon avis on
n'est pas loin de ce qui relève de la
moitié des uns et de la moitié des
autres mais c'est pas vraiment le sujet
moi je cherche pas parce que non c'est
le sujet pour le gouverne du nombre de
députés républicains
ou pas le vrai sujet ce sont les
convictions qu'on défend et je veux bien
passer pour un jusqu'au-boutiste peu
importe et je le redis et essuyer les
sarcasmes des uns et des autres qui
considèrent que ça suffit on devrait
s'aider au gouvernement maintenant on en
a assez tout ça on le fait pas pour nous
c'est pas la tactique politique tout ça
on le fait pour nos concitoyens et je
pense qu'en réunion de croupière y
compris sur le point que j’évoquais des
17-18 ans mais pas seulement sur le fait
que rentrer dans le dispositif carrière
longue c'est extrêmement sélectif je
pense que c'était pas la bonne piste
c'était pas la bonne idée de commencer à
tripatouiller le dispositif de très
longue que sur ce sujet il nous faut
encore avancer et puis au fond on a un
débat politique y compris en interne qui
est de se dire est-ce que demain les
Français nous feraient confiance parce
qu'on aurait ressemblé à Emmanuel Macron
moi je ne le crois pas je pense que les
Français nous feront confiance si on
repart au peuple et le peuple c'est ceux
qui aujourd'hui sont les plus pénalisés
par la réforme en l'état il y a 15 jours
de débat vous pouvez compter sur moi
pour me faire entendre en cohérence avec
ce que vous avez voté ça fait 4 ans que
le Sénat votre une réforme similaire
pendant les deux campagnes
présidentielles vous avez porté la
retraite à 65 ans est-ce qu'il y a pas
un moment vous l'entendez cette critique
sur le monde de cohérence des
républicains s'ils suivent votre
position je ne suis pas sénateur et si
j'avais été sénateur je n'aurais pas
voté continuellement la mesure telle
qu'elle a été proposée mais enfin il y a
quand même quelque chose de curieux
voilà deux élections voilà deux
élections présidentielles que nous
échouons durement
quel est le responsable politique qui se
dit alors que nous échouons alors que
nous avons fini à moins de 5%, il faut
continuer exactement de la même manière
j'assume de vous dire que depuis le
début depuis l'origine même si je suis
fidèle à ma famille politique et je le
resterai j'ai toujours été mal à l'aise
avec cette mesure lorsque en 2010
Nicolas Sarkozy porte la mesure
d'allongement de l'âge légal il veille à
avoir un renforcement du dispositif de
carrière longue parce que le cœur l'ADN
de la droite c'est de respecter les
travailleurs je ne pense pas que si nous
allons solliciter davantage celles et
ceux qui ont commencé à travailler tôt
on respecte les travailleurs voilà ce
qui pour moi est l'ADN de la droite
j'assume de vous dire clairement que
pour moi c'est la droite de se
reconstruire il faut aussi qu'elle
apprenne de temps en temps de ses
erreurs je le dis sereinement calmement
et je pense pouvoir discuter de cela
avec mes collègues y compris sénateurs
en trouvant un chemin qui nous rassemble
moi ce que j'ai du mal à comprendre j'ai
bien compris que vous n'étiez pas
sénateur j'ai bien compris que vous
n'étiez pas le pote d'Elizabeth vos
propos par contre vous êtes
vice-président du parti les républicains
il n'y a pas une il n'y a pas une ligne
du parti il y a pas une logique qui se
dégage à l'échelle de votre famille
politique et il y a pas un moment où il
y a une espèce de discipline qui
s'impose et de d'action de groupe qu'on
perçoit pas en fait dans ce que dans
votre positionnement et lorsque vous
nous dites vous avez le souvenir que
Charles Pasqua Philippe Seguin était
extrêmement discipliné au RPR tout est
normal c'est la tradition c'est la
culture de la maison non c'est
simplement que je ne suis pas un pot
qu'on pose sur une table je suis un
député comme mes autres collègues et
qu'il va falloir que chacun comprenne
bien que même dans une famille politique
on peut avoir des convictions et que ça
se respecte ça se respecte les
conditions donc le fait de ne pas être
d'accord c'est pas dramatique ça nous
est arrivé par le passé et on travaille
à faire en sorte qu'on puisse devenir
d'accord des convictions et la volonté
de bien montrer que vous êtes opposé à
l'action gouvernementale mais moi je
vous le redis je ne sais pas partie
d'une coal avec le gouvernement mais
d'ailleurs personne dans ma famille
politique à quelques rares exceptions
près on cette intention là oui je ne
fais pas partie de la coalition avec
Emmanuel Macron pour une raison très
simple c'est que son projet politique
n'est pas le mien que sa manière de
traiter les Français n'est pas celle que
je souhaite pour mon pays ah rien de
grave ce que j'ai toujours dit depuis
plusieurs années que je continuerai à
dire des
sénateurs.fr une réforme est toujours
améliorable mais aujourd'hui je ne sais
pas si certains visent l'amélioration ou
la démolition vous sentez viser par ses
propos non pas particulièrement Bruno
Retailleau a raison il faut continuer à
améliorer il y a plein de choses à
améliorer je m'interroge juste sur
une impression étonnante depuis quelques
temps le courage politique consisterait
à vouloir faire du mal aux Français
dès lors que vous êtes injuste avec les
Français vous seriez courageux mais moi
je ne crois pas je pense qu'on peut être
courageux en politique en étant juste
avec nos concitoyens oui est-ce que
c'est très réforme là qui aujourd'hui
pèse exclusivement sur celles et ceux
qui ont commencé à travailler tôt et
juste non est-ce qu'elle est améliorable
sur moi est-ce que le gouvernement le
souhaite je n'en sais rien en tous les
cas c'est le sens de mon engagement et
je dis à Bruno Retailleau comme à mes
autres amis politique le courage
politique ce n'est pas de vouloir faire
du mal aux Français c'est aussi de
vouloir les respecter est-ce que vous
demandez au gouvernement de retirer sa
réforme et de la retravailler avant de
la représenter au Parlement je ne l'ai
jamais demandé j'ai toujours voulu que
nous puissions mener la bataille la
question mais ce n'est pas mon cœur il
faut pas la retirer vous savez depuis
l'origine ma position est la même j'ai
dit que si les mesures que nous portions
notamment celles sur les moines de 21
ans était adoptés je voterai la réforme
je n'ai pas varié d'un millimètre et
c'est votre seule ligne rouge c'est que
j'ai toujours fixé les autres ont été
atteintes c'est celle que j'ai fixée
depuis plusieurs mois et ma parole vous
sauf que si cette ligne là n'est pas
atteinte je n'aurais aucune raison
objective de voter le texte je me
dégusterai de mes convictions voilà ce
que je dis aux uns et aux autres vous
votez encore contre alors où on se parle
bien sûr parce qu'il n'y a pas eu
d'évolution on a 15 jours de débat je me
demande pas le retrait du texte vous
savez au passage il faut se souvenir
d'une chose c'est que Elizabeth borne
joue une danse à mon avis assez cynique
avec les républicains faut pas s'y
tromper elle ne voit pas de bien du tout
soyons clairs les caresses de chat en
général ne sont pas extrêmement sincères
mais il y a une autre bataille qui
Elizabeth borne va devoir mener c'est
devant les Français il va falloir
qu'elle arrive à convaincre les Français
et ça c'est pas gagné et c'est une autre
étape y compris les syndicats parmi les
plus réformateurs qui aujourd'hui ne
sont pas convaincus est-ce que vous
dites quand vous avez Bertrand qu'avec
ceci n'est pas assez ferme avec le
gouvernement je n'ai aucune critique à
porter ni eriki ni à Xavier Bertrand je
dis simplement que je vous le redis les
labelsboard n'est pas ma complice je
pense pas qu'elle le soit pour
erikiotti non plus et que l'essentiel
c'est de se battre pour nos concitoyens
mais ça nous le partageons avec
une question sur l'index des seniors
peut-être un mot là-dessus qui a un
angle mort de cette de cette réforme et
qui a un gros problème est-ce que vous
pensez que le on peut on peut arriver à
améliorer l'emploi des seniors en France
le taux d'emploi des seniors est très
bas
on instaurant pas de mesure coercitives
est-ce qu'il faut des sanctions autour
de ces questions ou pas vous pensez
vraiment qu'on va relever ce défi
gigantesque de l'emploi des seniors avec
un index pensez vraiment qu'on va le
relever avec des amendes enfin c'est une
pardon mais mais c'est parce que vous
dites c'est ne rien comprendre aux
enjeux l'enjeu capital de cette réforme
des retraites il est double le rapport
au travail nous devons travailler plus
tout au long de sa vie c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que j'ai proposé qu'on avance
sur la semaine de quatre jours en 36 à
38 heures à l'époque quand je le disais
tout le monde s'arrachait les cheveux or
aujourd'hui ça fait partie du débat
public comme quoi de temps en temps
c'est pas mal d'explorer des chemins et
le deuxième sujet c'est de faire en
sorte qu'on travaille jusqu'à l'âge
légal le problème aujourd'hui c'est
notre système est déficitaire notamment
parce que les Français ne vont pas
jusqu'à la limite de l'âge légal parce
que l'emploi des seniors est très bas et
ça c'est un travail de fond ce n'est pas
avec un index qu'on le réglera ça me
permet de vous dire aussi à quel point
sur cette réforme des retraites je
regrette profondément qu'on soit passé à
côté des grands enjeux qui sont au-delà
des enjeux paramétriques merci Aurélien
merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
ce matin la innovation c'est ce séisme
c'est séisme meurtrier en Turquie et en
Syrie qui ont fait des milliers de morts
c'est à la Une de Ouest-France merci
Stéphane Mercier on passe au club des
territoires